uh sam bankman freed had this whole
thread uh last night about stocks
bitcoin war et cetera he basically
talked about you know it makes sense the
stocks are down in the kind of very
immediate term uh bitcoin as well people
are selling things to get cash
uncertainty all of that liquidity et
cetera um but
he also talked about let's start with
destabilizing eastern european
currencies uh and the eastern european
financial systems which means that they
might look for alternatives uh if you
were in ukraine right now where would
you trust your money so like that was
one of his like early points uh and i
think this is really fascinating because
ultimately uh we usually think about
people seeking alternatives to their
local currency because of undisciplined
monetary fiscal policy your currency's
failing [ __ ] i got to get something else
i want dollars i can't get dollars for
whatever reason my bank's gonna
confiscate it it's dangerous in the
black market it's expensive whatever
screw it what's on the internet let me
go do something there or let me get
physical gold hope somebody doesn't
confiscate it as i'm leaving whatever
yeah yeah totally
when you start thinking about it from a
war perspective you start thinking about
it from literally a uh
is my government gonna be around there's
reports all morning that uh uh russian
forces are trying to literally take the
government they're trying to install new
leadership they're trying to take over
uh their chernobyl plan like i mean this
is like an invasion of in on the
invasion scale this is like true
invasion right this is the rules yeah
this isn't like hey we like shot some
rockets and like did we use they drove
tanks to the capital yes
and so it does beg the question of like
okay if you're one of the thousands of
people that we pulled up that are
literally leaving uh kiev
what do you do with your wealth do you
leave it in a ukrainian bank
do you
put some gold in the trunk and hope to
god no one stops you
do you hope that you have enough
physical cash
to put in your pocket and that you
prepared for this situation like these
are real things and if you're sitting
there
thinking about this like
it's not that oh i'm gonna get rich with
bitcoin like whether it's stable coins
bitcoin whatever asset
there's like a very real consequence to
having these assets now and are an
advantage to having them yeah so
starters um
obviously digital assets are a cheap and
if not cheap uh certainly an effective
solution for people in these trying
times i'm not sure that everybody in
ukraine is this particular juncture has
the ability to remove their money out of
banks and and put them in digital asset
space
but to the extent that you're already
trapped in that financial system
buy stocks
like the the blue chip ukrainian
businesses and that may be an oxymoron
i'm not too familiar with how rock and
roll and ukraine's economy normally is
but to the extent that there are blue
chip businesses you know like the best
grocery store in ukraine you know the
uber of ukraine you know you know you
know all those kinds of companies
they're not going anywhere you know
they're still going to operate and exist
they might be under different leadership
they might be under uh putin's buddy
running the company in six months but
you know they're still going to be
generating capital generating profits
and ultimately servicing the ukraine
economy so
if i was i would be much more concerned
about having money in physical ukrainian
dollars what's their currency ukrainian
slotney or mm-hmm yeah so yeah um
i don't know how the hell i knew that
that's ridiculous
it's because you're smart yeah a lot
that's just i'm such a nerd um anyway
but no like you you don't want your
money in in the local currency so
clearly stocks tend to inflate when
there's a hyperinflation episode which
again hyperinflation in my book or in a
lot of economist books is defined by a
loss of confidence in the currency not
necessarily by a certain level of
threshold of inflation but rather an
actual absolute collapse in the currency
you could see a collapse in the currency
if we thought if the regime was to
change or if there was a fear that the
regime was going to change right um and
so you're definitely going to buy assets
that russians themselves with russian
rubles would want to buy um that would
be the best trade
john before you ask your question john
kerry gave an interview i guess this
morning and he said uh i hope that uh
vladimir putin helps us stay on track
for our climate goals
it's like wow geez louise man
that wasn't on the bingo card
not at all what questions you have yeah
i i agree that like ukrainian businesses
the infrastructure will be there no
matter the leadership like they will
eventually come somewhat relative back
to normal whoever's in power um the
country itself that will operate yeah
totally what do people around the world
talk about u.s ukraine citizens russian
um obviously everyone's very fearful
right now right buying they don't know
what's going to happen in the future
with the stock market is it right to be
fearful or is this the the time where
hey kind of
be greedy when others are fearful and
vice versa like is it's okay to be
grateful
fearful right now or what are your
thoughts around that uh it's i i tend to
think that fear and greed are two
emotions that cause you to lose the most
money in financial markets um so
generally speaking if you can obviously
it's impossible because we're all human
right uh we all make more decisions that
we need to make in terms of you know
risk managing our portfolios and things
of that nature but
i think it's best to just make
calculated bets based on where we are in
these various cycles again there's
geopolitics which is hard to ever truly
handicap engage but you can understand
where you are in the growth cycle you
can't understand where you are on the
inflation cycle you can understand where
you are in the monetary and fiscal
policy cycles and then also you can't
understand where you are in the
valuation cycle and most all those
cycles right now all five of them are
moving in the wrong direction
uh and so to me i think if you're saying
sort of there's blood in the streets by
yeah over a long enough time horizon
risk assets you know stocks crypto all
this stuff goes up in price over time
one because there's an expansion of the
money supply
but more importantly there's an
expansion of the human supply and
obviously we're gonna have create
economic activity and economic growth
just as a function of you know having
babies and you know being alive and
advances in medicine and so that stuff
if you have a long enough time horizon
it's always a good enough a great time
to buy an all-time high is a great time
to buy if you have a long enough time
horizon um but the problem is
most people particularly people at or
near retirement
cannot afford to suffer material
drawdowns and this is where the whole
concept of risk management comes into
play it's it's not about people who can
you know huddle bitcoins you know for 20
30 years which is what most people
should be doing obviously it's about the
people who the reason we see selling
ever is the people who are who cannot
afford a big drawdown get nervous about
their asset allocation and start to make
uh decisions that broadly impact
financial markets and so that's what
we're dealing with now that's what we'll
be dealing with for the rest of human
time until we have you know some sort of
universal i'm not again i'm certainly
not advocating this so don't shoot me
some sort of like universal retirement
program or basic income or but obviously
we're probably you know that's many many
many many many years away from occurring
in the us if ever
so have enough money to weather the
storm essentially right at the time yeah
and most people do not right the average
person does not right the average person
is a lot richer than they were prior to
the pandemic um but i think inflation
has taken a real big bite out of that
for the median to below median consumer
from an income perspective so uh but i
think we're about probably for a lot of
people we're worse off than where we
started and for a lot of people were
slightly better off and and getting less
better off by the day in terms of
declines in asset prices